if you treat him like the human being
not like a caged animal I like a person
who's a terrorist they know what they
did was wrong what they did was for a
cause but still they're still a human
being you get to go home you get to call
your families you check your email get
to watch TV you know that they've been
locked inside these cells for seven
years let me tell you they know the
rules better you do as part of their
training new guards are entering the
cell blocks with detainees for the first
time
[Music]
I've been in four years in the Navy and
I was trained to set up communications
between us and the ship's ma one Watson
has been in the Navy for 12 years he
helps train the new guards we're talking
about handling detainees we are not
judges
we're just guards
[Music]
in our daily interactions with these
people we know they are human beings so
the underlying principle is to always be
fair be firm and impartial okay what is
the size 5x
supposing I find myself in their shoes
as a prisoner of war someday somewhere
you know nobody knows but if I am
treated fairly firmly and impartially I
think that is fair enough
some devout Muslims avert their eyes in
the presence of a woman the detainees
weren't looking at me they were walking
back towards the back of the cell once I
came close to the cell this is nature
for the men and the woman when they are
meeting each other
it's feeling something and we'll have to
be very careful with the woman when the
woman they were coming to some block or
something the prisoner they were
Caviezel buzzer buzzer buzzer mean and
to care for your eyes Darwin do not look
to the owe me something is coming to do
send with you in to go to Perdition not
likely this kind of thing
I've been here for exactly seven days
one week we came here and everybody that
was in my company everyone was petrified
beyond belief
it's intense to look at you guys the of
an actual terrorist
how do you think it would feel I could
you even imagine living in the cell I'm
not sure about the dimensions
[Music]
a lot of it's crazy but it's real and
everybody loves it
[Applause]
you